Gracias y bienvenida directo a América
muchas gracias a ustedes por esta
invitación vamos a empezar con lo que se
ha hablado en esta feria del libro de
Bogotá y lo son los primeros 15 años de
coleccionistas de polvos raros para Ir
calentando Quiero preguntarle sobre esta
segunda novela usted ha regresado a esta
novela más a propósito Pues de este
aniversario y cómo ha sido ese
reencontrarse con este escrito que ya
tiene su tiempo Ay a mí para mí fue una
experiencia muy impresionante
reencontrarme con la novela porque pues
uno termina la novela y quiere olvidarse
un poco de ella porque ya pasa a ser de
los lectores y para la reedición
obviamente la la volvimos a leer le
hicimos unos pequeños ajustes como no sé
en errores que que habían quedado en la
en la primera edición en frases que de
repente estaban un poquito torcidas
entonces las enderezamos me
sorprendieron varias cosas una sobre
todo la actualidad de la novela esta
novela fue complicada por primera vez en
el año 2007 antes de los movimientos
feministas del mitú antes del estallido
social en Colombia pero todo eso que
pasó durante el mitú que pasó durante el
estallido feminista y durante el
estallido social en Colombia está
retratado ahí no nos muestra a Cali Como
una ciudad profundamente desigual
segregada donde los ricos y los pobres
están absolutamente separados y de
repente entra una fuerza en la ciudad
que es el narcotráfico que que funciona
un poco como una Revolución y es que
permite el ascenso social y Esta es una
novela que que narra el ascenso social
de una mujer a través de
ese dinero del narcotráfico no y creo
que también nos muestra cómo es una
ciudad racista excluyente con el
diferente que fue algo que todos pudimos
ver durante el estallido social en
Colombia Y eso es algo que para los
lectores pues lo mejor que pueden hacer
es simplemente leer la novela porque yo
no quisiera ahondar demasiado en las
historias porque siento que es un
spoiler para los lectores y es mejor que
se adentren en lo que es la historia de
la vida de la flaca y la vida de esa
Cali antes y después de una época muy
fuerte del narcotráfico pero también me
llama la atención que sus novelas hablan
de esas situaciones no de esas
oportunidades que nos atraviesan
particularmente a las mujeres que
cambian nuestros modos de vida y que
tiene que ver mucho con nuestros dolores
y con las desprotecciones que sufrimos
Pues a lo largo de todo Nuestro camino y
aquí pues esta parte Me parece muy
emocionante porque porque quiero hablar
de la perra
entonces voy a comenzar contándole Mi
historia Y a partir de ahí le voy a
preguntar yo leí la perra hace unos años
y pasa mucho a veces con los libros que
uno los lee y con el tiempo uno va
olvidando detalles de las historias Pero
uno sí se acuerda de cómo se sintió
cuando lo leyó o cómo se sintió ese
guayabo cuando termina de leer libro y
en ese momento Yo no entendía que era
ese dolor profundo que me generaba la
perra Más allá de los dramas de de su
protagonista Damaris y de la perra que
es Shirley
hasta hace algunos años y lo que cambió
todo fue pasar por la maternidad y ahí
dije Ah eso era y entendí hace muy poco
que la perra es un libro que desafía
mucho las ideas románticas de la
maternidad que nos obliga a revisar lo
que es la maternidad y lo que es para
una mujer y en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad que es casi regla general
en América Latina ni siquiera en
Colombia atravesar una maternidad sin
apoyo atravesar una maternidad sin
conocimiento en condiciones de
disfuncionalidad
hablemos de eso
yo pienso bueno la perra es una novela
sobre un deseo incumplido no es una
mujer en el momento en que yo la estaba
escribiendo quizás estaba los
movimientos feministas en redes muy
alborotados reivindicando los de El
derecho de la mujer a no ser madre lo
cual a mí me parece magnífico pero algo
adentro a mí me decía y qué pasa con las
mujeres que sí quieren serlo quien está
hablando por ellas no quién está
retratando ese profundo deseo de algunas
mujeres que quieren de verdad tener un
hijo no Y el dolor de no poder ser
madres nos nos a nosotros se nos permite
hablar de
los momentos y de las situaciones
alegres de la maternidad No el amor lo
maravilloso que es las cosas bonitas que
sentimos pero no de los fracasos que
vienen con la maternidad no De cuántos
embarazos terminan en abortos
espontáneos en pérdidas no
más del 20% de los embarazos terminan en
una pérdida muchas mujeres hemos tenido
pérdidas pero no hablamos de ello
abiertamente porque es un tema en el que
mejor de eso no hablamos no ni tampoco
de las dificultades de la maternidad de
lo difícil que es se nos ha vendido la
idea de una mamá como una señora peinada
y maquillada que da teta con alegría no
Johnson y Johnson y
es feliz y todo es maravilloso cuando
hemos tenido un bebé sabemos que esas
son semanas horribles donde estás
sangrando tu cuerpo es desconocido no
está bonito no te gusta tu nuevo cuerpo
porque no te has acostumbrado a él todo
duele amamantar duele el muchachito o la
muchachita llora todo el tiempo estamos
mal dormidos tenemos ojeras no y de eso
Pues de eso no se habla entonces yo creo
que en la perra exploramos el lado más
oscuro de la maternidad y del deseo de
ser madre y de cómo un sueño cumplido el
sueño de ser mamá pues a ver pues no es
un jardín de rosas y a veces puede ser
una pesadilla puede volverse en una
pesadilla no solamente en el libro esto
es la vida real de la que no hablamos
porque lo mantenemos en el ámbito
privado y a veces ni siquiera nos
atrevemos a aceptarlo al inicio del
libro cuando Damaris da con la perrita
que es una bebé Claro llega este momento
en el que ella dice la recoge la le cabe
entre sus manos le huele a leche la
abraza contra su pecho esto es
perfectamente la descripción de una
madre nueva que tiene toda la
expectativa de un mundo un mundo nuevo
que acaba de crear y luego con ese mundo
pues vienen todas las dificultades que
usted está escribiendo y entonces la
perra es un libro que termina siendo
dramático que termina siendo doloroso
pero que también termina reivindicando
la valía de sentir de sentir dentro de
dentro de lo que es ser una mujer en el
mundo y además que usted lo explora nada
más y nada menos que en el Pacífico
colombiano no Entonces en un ambiente de
selva en un ambiente de mar en un además
de empobrecimiento de vulnerabilidad
donde no hay herramientas no y aquí
volvemos al tema de las oportunidades no
cómo es de diferente el panorama para
Damaris debido a su contexto y venía
pensando antes de esta entrevista Cómo
habría sido una Damaris que no sufriera
por sentir que algo le faltaba no que no
que no se sintiera incompleta por no ser
madre que hubiera podido ser feliz claro
que hubiera tenido herramientas que
hubiera podido ir al psicólogo o adoptar
un bebé o hacerse tratamientos de
fertilidad no tener herramientas para
las para salir de ese lugar de
frustración que no las tuvo bueno Y al
final tenemos en los tres libros que
estamos mostrando para esta entrevista
de todos los que usted ha escrito a
Claudia de ocho años que también vive en
una además muy pintoresca en una Cali
que uno huele que uno siente que a uno
le da calor estar ahí que vive en un
apartamento que es como una selva lleno
de matas con una mamá que seguramente
para muchos es la mamá más bonita del
mundo pero que no es una mamá perfecta y
aquí otra vez esa dicotomía de las
maternidades y de unas
disfuncionalidades en las que sin
embargo
Claudia termina muchas veces salvando a
su mamá no y reivindicando a su mamá en
sus en su humanidad Sí sí desde una mamá
imperfecta como todas no que a veces
hacia afuera cuando las vemos de afuera
nos parecen que son la mamá perfecta
pero porque no las conocemos cómo se
portan adentro de la casa y que les pasa
no tienen como las máscaras el
maquillaje la apariencia para dar la
impresión de lo que se espera que una
mujer sea no la mamá de Claudia también
se llama Claudia es una mujer que no
pudo tampoco que siendo privilegiada no
pudo elegir lo que ella quería hacer
porque pertenecía a una generación donde
el lugar debido de la mujer seguía
siendo la familia el hogar tener hijos y
de repente se encuentra siendo mamá
porque eso era lo que le tocaba y de
repente no está cómoda en ese lugar no
es casi como como el negativo de Damaris
damari es una mujer que quiere tener si
no lo consigue y Claudia es una mujer
que de repente no hubiera querido tener
hijos pero se encuentra siendo madre ya
se nos acaba el tiempo Pilar y Que
lástima yo sabía que no nos iba a
alcanzar para hablar demasiado pero hay
algo que no quiero dejar fuera y es la
biblioteca de escritoras colombianas
este proyecto del Ministerio de cultura
de Colombia del que usted es editora y
esto Me parece muy importante muy
importante porque no no puede ser que en
el 2023 todavía siga siendo el lugar
como en Buscar escritores cuando hay
escritoras tantas tantas para
referenciar tantas para hablar y usted
misma se ha abierto camino a través de
un mundo de escritores hombres así es
bueno ese es un proyecto bellísimo
publicamos ya 18 libros de algunas de
las autoras más sobresalientes de
Colombia desde la colonia hasta la
primera mitad del siglo XX y la buena
noticia que no la ha dado y esta Va a
ser la primera vez que la doy es que ya
empezamos la segunda fase del proyecto y
esperamos para 2024 publicar una
colección de antologías más autoras
colombianas olvidadas que no circularon
como debían o que fueron que no que no
tienen en este momento el lugar que
merecen
vamos a publicarlas para el año
siguiente pues mire Pilar ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo gracias a usted por
sus historias pero también gracias
porque no sé si a propósito o
simplemente la vida la llevó a volverse
una persona que moviliza por la lectura
y que moviliza por las mujeres autoras
que definitivamente como usted dice
merecen y necesitan tener un lugar en el
centro pues de todas las miradas y de
todas las palabras y tienen mucho para
aportarnos con sus historias a usted
Muchísimas gracias muchas gracias por
esta entrevista y también a nuestros
televidentes Gracias sigan con nosotros
en directo América sigan en France 24 y
nos vemos más adelante